I'm taking a 20 penny spike driver to a
2-inch piece of lumber one strike by
hearing I think the ladies to the lumber
newer isn't always better and this is
certainly true when it comes to working
out weightlifting physical training in
general an example of this comes from
the old-time strongmen these were the
classic original strong men who were
less known for their physiques and more
known for their incredible feats of
strength these guys existed in the time
before steroids and many of the
supplements that we use today and yet
they could achieve incredible feats of
strength some of which have never been
surpassed so what are their secrets what
are their techniques have gone into this
topic in more depth on my website but in
this video I'm going to break down just
a few of the unique approaches to
training that the old-time strongmen
would use and that maybe we can
incorporate into our own training as
well clean living no smoking no alcohol
no squandering your life nights by
playing cards in stuffy rooms
[Music]
so the first thing I want to look at is
grip strength grip strength is one of
the hallmarks of the old time strongman
they would build their grip strength
knowing that in many ways this was the
missing link if you will when it comes
to strength and performance lifting
weights your hands are your connection
to the weight and for doing things like
even bench press or deadlift they're
incredibly important and they're also
super important to things like
handstands in which case you're actually
gripping onto the floor slightly that
can help give you a better balance the
old-time strong men did a lot of cool
calisthenics moves and so it made sense
that they'd want great strength for that
reason too one of the big reasons that
old-time strongmen wanted
impressive grip strength was so that
they could avoid being shown up by
members of the audience so obviously if
you're supposed to be this awesome big
strong guy and the term come from the
audience comes up and they can
outperform you that doesn't look so good
so what the old-time strongmen would do
is they use barbells and dumbbells that
were wider so the actual bar was wider
that meant that they had to grip onto
the bars much harder in order to perform
the same exercises so if someone came up
and challenged them even if they're
strong enough to lift that amount of
weight normally they wouldn't be strong
enough to do it with the wider grip as
well so this is something we can
incorporate into our own training and
it's been shown to have all kinds of
benefits for your general health quick
strength has so how would you do it well
you could also do the same thing as the
all-time strongmen you could train by
using wider bars you can buy dumbbells
and barbells with with wider bars or you
could wrap something around the bar nose
to make it wider say a towel
another option is of course grip
trainers and many old times from men
would use those another option as well
see in a moment is a becoming isometrics
and static contraction and otherwise all
the usual stuff you can do wrist curls
you can do how pull-ups etc but the
take-home message here is focus on your
grip and if you get really good then you
might become as
P as Jo Holton who was known for
catching cannibals with his bare hands
although he did lose several fingers the
first time he tried it so I don't
recommend given that gay okay the next
one I want to talk about is muscle
control the mind muscle connection is
real if you don't believe me then how
come I can do this
as we wiggling my ears and it's not
because I have super bulky years I've
never trained my ear muscles it's
because the mind muscle connection for
my ears is greater I once
I saw my uncle do it and I deployed I
wanted to do it I stood in front the
mirror and I tried to try to try to
eventually have developed the connection
the ability to recruit the muscle fibers
necessary to move my ears and that's
what we're talking about here because
imagine if you could do the same things
to your biceps now the average person
doesn't contract 100% of their muscle
fiber well nobody does the average
person contracts about 30 percent
because they're lacking that mind-muscle
connection and I've gone into the detail
on that on other other video I'm not
going to do that now but one guy I'm
particularly interested in from way back
when is a guy called max ik his original
name was a max sick and he changed his
name because apparently dick in your
name isn't great for business when
you're supposed to be all about health
and fitness
max ik preached muscle control as he
called it and not only was he able to
recruit the muscle fiber he wanted to a
great degree he was also able to
actively relax the antagonistic muscle
so you're doing a bicep curl you're
using your biceps but at the same time
the tricep is actually pulling in the
opposite direction when you tense any
muscle when you can track any muscle the
one surrounding it contract too so it's
almost impossible to lift the biceps to
do a bicep curl without also engaging
the triceps and that's making it more
difficult for yourself but max ik claims
that he could actively relax the triceps
is such a degree that he gains way more
strength for all his lips you can
actually get his book where he talks
through how to increase your muscle
control for your scapular retractors I
think that's the right name etc etc he
describes how to actually feel the
muscle and build that connection and
since we know people like our shruts
mega have talked about how important is
to focus on the muscle when you're using
if you want to build it to its massive
potential
so how can you do this well you can use
the overcoming isometrics techniques
that I talk about all the time that are
coming up in a moment or why not buy his
book and read it that's what I'm doing
right now and when I say buy I mean
downloads he is long dead it turns out
though that some things never change
which brings me to my next point
progressive overload because all time
strongmen they might have had some weird
and different techniques to us they
might have eaten a whole load of eggs so
they also believe in just making their
weights heavier in order to get stronger
and nobody believes this more than Milo
of Croton you know that guy he has a
unique approach to progressive overload
so he would pick a baby calf you and
then he would adopt it I presume and
feed it and stuff and he would carry on
his back all the time this is like the
ultimate diva cast like if you try to
take it so it would be like carry me but
anyways this calf would obviously grow
over time and he'd get gradually
stronger because he was carrying the car
and so by the time the car support grown
cow and this guy was running around with
it on his back he'd be super strong but
you wouldn't even notice it getting that
much heavier because it started to light
and it grew so slowly because that's a
fairly ridiculous example and I'm not
recommending that you go and pick a car
you'll be shot by the farmer but what
you can do is something called micro
plating that's where you take your
exercise that you hit a plateau on say
the bench press and then you stick on
like 0.25 kilograms or whatever that is
in pounds on to the end
tiny tiny weight plate so you won't even
feel you do that next time the next time
the next time build it up and eventually
before you know it you've added ten
kilograms onto your bench and you didn't
even notice
so while old-time strongmen might seem
like a thing of the past actually many
of their principles are still being used
today by professional strongmen and you
know people who do strongman stuff for a
hobby you know there are still people
performing incredible feats of strength
and one way they train is one of the
same ways that many of the old-time
strongmen were trained and that's with
overcoming isometric static contraction
what that is I've talked about it before
is it is it's pulling or pushing against
something that won't move it's an
unstoppable object meets an immovable
force or the other way around and
basically what you're doing is for
example you're pushing gets the wall
you're pulling against the chain and
you're just doing that as hard as you
can there's one all-time strong man
whose name I forget but if I find it
I'll put it in the description below he
would actually go and try and push down
trees I mean how awesome is that always
train but more often it's overcoming
isometric would involve trying to crush
something with the grip again or or Bend
something so they often spend iron bars
as we know nails and today people are
ripping up phone books etc and again
this is something that I highly
recommend not necessarily ripping up the
phone books but this is the kind of task
of training you can do all the time not
build a completely different kind of
strength what helps you to recruit more
muscle fiber it will help you to
increase your grip strength I've heard
of people bending frying pans rolling
them up into instead of tubes I mean if
you can develop that kind of strength
then that's awesome and the only way to
develop it is to keep trying to do it
okay and something else that the old
time stronger would do quite differently
to where we train today is to use some
very unusual lift so we obviously have
how a deadlift our squat are clean and
press etc but these guys would use a
whole plethora of different moves
including things like the been
suppressed and that's completely weird
they'd be bent down and they'd lift a
weight over their heads in one arm this
is a barbell as well for their balancing
the things just the incredible amount of
control and balance that was involved
especially under such heavy weight is
incredible and that's probably why a guy
called Arthur Saxon who dates back to
19th century still holds the record for
that kind of list and it still hasn't
been broken today there's claims that
Eugen Sandow managed to equal his list
that they speak math official either way
though they're both old-time strongmen
and today long to do the same thing
because they're doing a different kind
of list one of the coolest types of list
is something called B anyhow lit and
this is just you grab as much weight as
you can when you put it in the air so
that could mean you pick something up
with your foot and you'd pick something
up with one hand and then you pull
something with the other hand however
you can do it just how much you can lift
and that just build
an incredible amount of strength is just
so different and it's just true
functional strength I mean you tell me
that a deadlift is functional but how
often do you do a deadlift in the wild
some probably never at all but on the
other hand what you do do is unexpected
move so if you can lift and incredible
weight in kind of any kind of weird way
well then that is true functional
strength and a lot of these old time
lists were unilateral one-armed so they
would lift the weight over their head
with one hand and this had an
interesting effect it built up their
oblique to be huge now the obliques are
the muscles on the side of the ABS they
used for talk they also use for bending
from side to side and by engaging in
this kind of training these guys built
up massive obliques which is something
again that we just don't really have
today so again if you want to train more
like an all-time strong man
it's no knee should you use more unusual
lift but maybe try doing more one-sided
lip and training those oblique they do
make a waist look a bit wider so if it's
just aesthetic to going for then you
know you have to weigh up the pros and
cons just to make it absolutely clear I
am no expert when it comes to these
unusual old-time strongman lips you
probably tell from the footage so I'm
sharing this because it's something I'm
very interested in researching at the
moment that's why I do I find unusual
types of physical and mental training
fascinating so I research it I try and
cooperating it into my workout and I
make these videos my training normally
consists largely of isolation exercises
which I'm going to do a video on in the
future why I think they still definitely
deserve a place in your workouts I do a
lot of calisthenics and I do do the
static contraction and the overcoming
isometric Scripps training at the moment
already but as I talked about in my
Batman videos I have now got a skilled
day training session in my routine where
I experiment with these different types
of training whether it's learning a new
move for parkour whether it's trying an
old-time strongman lifts so yes and
they're very interested in and I thought
was only fair that I give it a go on
video but if you want to have a go at
any of these lips I highly recommend you
look up an expert who knows what they're
doing and you can talk you through the
correct technique what I will say is
definitely start with a lightweight
don't jump straight into
everybody had one even just the bar with
no weight on it get your technique down
first you can see in the video I
struggle with the way I'm trying to do
it with so I drop down and then do a
little bit better but yeah I will be
incorporating this into my training
sticking with it for a while because I
find it particularly interesting and I
can see how it certainly would having
build a large strength the been pressed
in particular what you're doing here is
what makes it unique is that you're
moving away from the weight so to do it
correctly you have to wait in position
and then you bend down but the weight
doesn't move so your arm is extended and
pressed out over your heads by the end
but it's in the same with best position
is you who's moved away from the weight
and there's another move similar to this
which was again used a long time ago
more often called the squatting press
not to be confused as a squat press
won't you hear you hold it as though
you're going to do a front squat and
then you just you you squat down but you
hold the weight again in the exact same
position so that it's extended arm
stretched and then you stand up and
press it overhead finish with a squat
press so both these examples you're
moving away from the weight and that
requires a whole different kind of
coordination muscle control you're
involving a little supporting muscle
going right now I can feel my oblique my
back you know or having done a really
decent workout something quite different
than well balanced and you can see how
this could be quite practical so
especially if you're building up to an
anyhow lit says that you're holding say
one weight overhead in one arm what do
you mean well bend down pick up another
one up off the ground
athletes the best the way I can lift the
most weight is with a simple sport or a
bench press say to me that would never
work but if you're building up to those
huge numbers the best way to do is to
have one thing press overhead arm locks
out and then you can bend over and just
pick something up from the ground so you
can see how that kind of training would
build into that there's all kinds of
variations as well looking at it you've
got the side press for instance which
looks a lot like a bench press on paper
but actually the distances here you're
not now moving waste and weight it's
more conventional press you're leaning
to the side that's involving those
obliques a lot more so again the kind of
muscles that often get overlooked so
there's a lot to learn here I'll
definitely be trying more of it
and I'd love to know your experiences
and what you think of it and if there's
any particularly interesting list that I
haven't stopped you know about em you
know in the comments below because yeah
there was there's tons of these and I
mean they've all still got around today
so and it certainly makes for different
routines at different training session
if you want to mix things up a little
bit so there you go that's some unusual
training methods used by the old-time
strongmen that you can incorporate into
your own routines if you're more
interested in building power and
strengths and being formidable rather
than just you know developing those
mirror muscles and looking good which is
also perfectly acceptable and ever
whichever you prefer I like to aim for
performance and of course if you can
look a little bit good as well no bad
thing so let me know what you thought
about this in the comments below if you
found that interesting if you have know
of any I miss remember in the
description below I am including the
link to my article where I go into a bit
more detail include some time I missed
out here because I forget but yes I hope
you found it useful and interesting if
you did please like share and subscribe
definitely check out my website the bio
near comp where I generally go into tons
more detail and all sorts of things and
love it if you follow me on social media
got an Instagram account for Twitter and
I'm trying to keep them up to date
Facebook but you know it's it'd be great
if you could chat with me on there I'd
love to hear from you and also just
thanks so much for all of you who are
already subscribed and came from the
Batman video or the Bruce Lee video
channels been seeing a bit of momentum
lately which is just so great because
they're you know I love doing it it's a
real probably and a passion I mean it
doesn't it doesn't pay there cuz I love
it so thanks for being on this journey
with me
that sounds very cliche but true and
yeah I'll catch you next one have a
great day and bye for now